زياره الى واشنطن تزامنت مع عقد الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتن اجتماع الموسعا
لوزاره الدفاع لاستعراض نتائج انشطه
القوات المسلحه الروسيه في عام 2022
وتحديد المهمات للعام المقبل خلال
الاجتماع الذي وصفته وزاره الدفاع
بالمهمهم جدا اكد بوتن ان بلاده ستواصل
تطوير قدراتها العسكريه بما في ذلك
الاستعداد القتالي لقواتها النوويه الرئيس
الروسي
القدرات القتاليه والاستعدادات النوويه ما
يمثل ضمانا لسياده روسيا ووحده اراضيها
وبشكل عام الرد على النووي والتوازن
النووي في العالم وقد تم تجهيز القوات
النوويه بنسبه 91% وايضا تم تزويد قواتنا
بمنظومه فرط الصوتيه وايضا تم تزويد
القوات للمره الاولى بمنظومه الصواريخ
العابره
اضافه الى ذلك اعلن الرئيس الروسي انه في
مطلع يناير ستكون الفرقات اميرال جوش كوف
في الخدمه ومزوده بصواريخ زركون فرط
الصوتيه التي لا مثيل لها في العالم وفقفه
اما وزير دفاعه سرقه شويجو فذكر ان روسيا
تقاتل في اوكرانيا قوات الغرب المتضافره
ذلك بسبب دعمها المالي وشحنات الاسلحه
المكثفه لك يافا
[موسيقى]
وسعي الغربي الى ايطاليا والاعمال
القتاليه في اوكرانيا
والمعدات القتاليه الروسيه اثبتتت جدارتها
على ارض المعركه هذه العمليه تعطي فرصه
نديره لتحليل اساليب القتاليه الحديثه
واخوض المعركه التي تشارك فيها انواع
مختلفه من القوات العسكريه